[Music]
everyone thinks anarchy is uh
do whatever you want
anarchy just means self-ownership the
most peaceful ideology in the world
the state has oppressed me since birth i
was wanting more freedom and wanting to
be controlled less we wanted a pure
anarchist life for our kids donated
mexico this is a solution
what would you think about conference in
mexico people just like you and i who
question authority who want to live
differently in acapulco it will change
your life
no we don't want unharmed people here
it's going to be [ __ ] happening
biggest anarchist conference trip to
mexico i'm really excited
the world is waking up my best friends
are anarchists [ __ ] the government
most of our people were buying into
bitcoin
coming in on private jets and yachts
[Music]
this beautiful paradise can be a beacon
of freedom for people to migrate to
[Music]
and then the murder happened
tragic situation there was some sketchy
stuff happening behind the scenes
you need to stop or there's going to be
serious consequences you listen
or you die
i heard i'm scared out of my mind there
was a legitimate fear that there's a
bomb at conference
at which point we were like what the
[ __ ]
crypto crash
we were struggling we're all pretty
desperate it's amazing how destructive
human beings can be if they decide to
not cooperate and play nice
there's a lot of bloodshed in the city
just all over the place this is real
anarchy here
this is not okay
not okay at all
they are going to come after us
we have to be strong
is there a limit to the sacrifice that
you're willing to make
to fix the broken world
the blood is in the streets
what are you gonna do
[Music]
are we strong
[Applause]
you